down by 14 the Lakers to within to the
press over the touched
[Music]
bangs it off the backboard and
you saw we see green can't connect it
goes right to kcp green lobster have
their first lead
basically as they go up on Gilligan's
Island Los Angeles welcome Bob dead
that's good cut by Casey up by July
they're powered by the way the top five
and NBA block shots already this year
but brought all the way the bronze and
score
Howard on the offensive glass this flush
you brought in after the official why
he's not at the line mr. Sibley was just
a shot there's a difference
oh yeah show you that play worked white
it's to pass from Avery and look at that
thing go down good lob a much better
finishing hurdle talk about a bad boy
that was off the glass and a slam by
Dwight as we get another look going to
break as a rebound by Wright and the
finish what most of the illegal
defensive mode dr. Rosen
[Music]
about the rim again was a good play was
the rebound on the missed by LeBron as
easier and just rushes to a great start
to the fourth for dial Koosman breathe
and the Lakers are only down by four
just get rid of Cornett rebound and
Hamilton last Lakers starters it's
Gordon was LeBron with a minute half
left of the third Dwight the points are
just about even Toronto's got one more
than the Lakers and off not Avery
Bradley that makes it easy the first
time they did it you throw up the LOB
and Dwight hammered went home and then
this time we're down by two workouts
boats don't fight white Howard after the
lob will allow to you for Danny Green
urgently facts
passed out again but they've been
milkiness until the defense makes the
adjustment you keep running the same
flight it's got some real skills tell
the truth don't like he didn't lose some
weight 50 170 pounds yeah give him the
credit he worked his tail off as
white-hot with the finish in the paint
kruseman
nice feed inside this time Howard
now as well I think it was a foul it's
just good basketball could have been a
tech hanging on the rim I think he's
still on it this guy has been nothing
but a pro while I see guys jump up and
down and want to be seen been a pro
supportive of his head coach and getting
the job done it should be acknowledged
LeBron James with yet another assist and
white Howard finishes glad to bring it
to you we'll be on the air again on
Sunday night currently it's a Ted old
lunch bounce to Draghi with two hands
throws it down they gave him a break
here
[Applause]
control the chances now to Dwight Howard
not but to the threat to shoot them out
there here's Casey P cooked white what a
perfect play came around that pic we see
the Lakers run that play a couple more
minutes than LeBron tonight right there
to take the air ball and slam it threw
himself on back in to start the quarter
has his Dwight Howard but what great
fine Dwight Howard has been to the
Lakers Davis and one thing about Dwight
Howard he stayed true in word their ears
on killed whites and weights this year
guys he shrunk to six seven he used to
be listed 610 white still playing
bhinneka on the alley-oop kind of
thinking to save things a pot for Howard
in the vinegar
caldwell-pope with the assist on the
play the Lakers thanks giving a holiday
weekend Lakers and LeBron best record in
the NBA
[Applause]
just serve it up it's a technical foul
for taunting nice bounce pass by Caruso
really was nice strong finish by the
right couple of assists for Caruso
Dwight eight points five boards to split
the defense does Oh towel has it Powell
down the middle loose control no not
make this happen uppers if they want
LeBron bouncing power definitely distort
good vision by LeBron obviously set up
it does that have to quick Rondo really
in the middle of all of that
read read soda that Dwight throw it down
Lakers by eight rot down not a LeBron
path to the basket but a great little
lob pass to joy as all the attention
turned to LBJ other plays look at that
playroom
the bran throws it up Dwight throws it
down this recognition and knowing who's
available in the double-team gums
[Music]
[Applause]
and the other end it's a cleanup time
fort white Howard
make your plans to do with us that those
ticket exchange Sarah perfectly cut up
and served up by LeBron minute mark who
make sure it's down with to Bremen waits
for to be thrown up and he throws it
down with basketball hands is poised as
the store
try for a dog Rondo gave it right to of
the alley this is his latest one those
always late getting back tips not let go
[Applause]
k CP play where he threw it up and
Dwight elevating and throwing it 162 108
still hauling an eight point lead and
eight minutes to play look rod the
double and it goes right to quite pretty
alley use his Lakers team is third in
defensive efficiency Dudley with a nice
fake Howard there to clean it up
now it's look like the first official
first of the hand it's a highlight reel
[Applause]
is their leading scorer also six the
entire league and assist CP that's a
good feed and the two-hand dunk fights
white with JCB get he really lost you
told the world another great Showtime
feed from James to Dwight Rondo's
control swings quarterbacks during the
three 6:52 go 2nd quarter Lakers lead by
one
Dwight our easy doesn't did that play
were white tails just by his actions
till
sit down full rank go to the drill this
time it's a lot to try it it was right
there at the rib just served it up
another look at that play with Danny
throws without can glide there hoops it
down as very
cook the soon you go to any hour you
ripped away this time it savory
grappling with the steel they got
knocked down got up and got the screw
now away we get it at the other end
lopped it's white who's the recipient
one more time teeing off the bench with
white white acetate great
it's nine for nine for Howard on the
dish by Alex the Lakers with a
three-point lead at the ball get in
LeBron running it to LBJ the LOB to try
another look at that LeBron logged to
Dwight and right with a monster finis
leave me a cell you know he don't play
every night the empties in the last
seven games staying with it there is
Dwight Howard to clean up the Miss by
Davis you're on Co cheeks when I see you
I see you get defensive play tend to the
potential three-point plays dwight
howard having little UCLA cut Kuzma
misses off a good block
and when Harald rotates over Lou
Williams has to pull in to Dwight Howard
[Music]
for LBJ parameter calling no shot as we
get another look at LeBron finding white
for the easiest do stood wide he'll get
tonight
Dwight cheetah 7,500 cuts it down to a
seven-point game the 34 year old
Tolliver creature charisma the audio and
white throws it down not another Rondo
assists how is his first rebound of the
night his clues but now he is looking
for a new season I can't get it twice
there Chuck clean it up Rondo with 10 to
shoot over both the caldwell-pope those
will authority never look at that
playing with kcp gives the assist on
Dwight Howard after this green one right
down the gut and getting the
easy flush Jackson third year out of
North Carolina LeBron James sets the
screen for Rondo there's a lot to Dwight
Howard with the slash Knight a franchise
record 24 three-pointers here's James
just 2 points so far then a trade slobs
out there for his fifth assist this
Howard stops it doesn't set a screen a
little brush screen and then dive to the
cup you're getting James trying to fight
through a screen and get the ball with
Vinnie Smith on him backing him down oh
what a pass by James soaring venison
plus assists by accident this is a true
quarterback on the floor forces the
defense to adjust once they make a
decision to drop off pass to Dwight
Howard and he does the rest
and Caruso driving fine tower for
another job
and the fact again he's playing through
injury I mean there was talk that hey
he's gonna miss some time after the
injury on Christmas Day no he plays a
back to back again they keep him away
from the rim the versatility of Anthony
Davis feel powerful with Slash Santa
bringing the ball up the floor get a
hold back against James and Davis when
comparing them with some of the all-time
great Lakers players second round but it
was not bad the vision three year old
already in his fifth year former number
15 pick in the draft
LeBron looks to attach lob this time
it's Dwight to holidays I'll statement
defendant but you're asking him to
defend Anthony Davis that's the lad the
next-to-last basket is quite possibly
trying to offset all those free-throw
Graham yeah they're -90 though with the
big score boy certainly looked like he
wanted the little runner but Dwight was
right there thank you what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content